[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce jeudi 14 juin top départ de
la grande fête du football la coupe du
monde a débuté aujourd'hui en russie
dans ce journal nous vous emmenons à
jouer en josas là où s'entraînaient
l'équipe de france il ya 30 ans nous
aurons également par téléphone
karl olive depuis la russie le maire de
poissy et chargé de mission par la fifa
pendant l'événement c'est la journée
mondiale des donneurs de sang chaque
mois désormais au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous pouvez
faire un don
la scène nationale située à montigny le
bretonneux met à disposition une salle
elle permet d'accueillir plus de
personnes dans de meilleures conditions
reportage et puis le camp est installé
illégalement dans le quartier de la
bretonnière à voisins le bretonneux une
soixantaine de caravanes des gens du
voyage est arrivé la semaine dernière la
communauté s'engage à partir le 23 juin
et puis on évoquera un autre grand
événement sportif enfin d'édition du
golfe avec la ryder cup bien sûr trois
repas de gala
elles seront organisées à cette occasion
au profit de l'association handigolf on
vous en dit plus tout à l'heure mais
avant de développer ces titres le drame
survenu à villepreux une femme enceinte
de huit mois est décédé dans un accident
de la route survenu hier après midi sur
la rd 98
un adolescent de 11 ans est lui en état
de mort clinique et deux enfants et
leurs parents sont également entre la
vie et la mort un choc frontal entre
deux véhicules est à l'origine de
l'accident est l'un des automobilistes
aurait perdu le contrôle de sa voiture
dans une courbe l' enquête a été confiée
au commissariat de plaisir 3,2 milliards
de téléspectateurs ont regardé la
précédente édition au brésil la coupe du
monde 2018 a débuté en russie à l'heure
où je vous reparle alors je vous parle
d'ailleurs par dont le match d'ouverture
entre la russie et l'arabie saoudite se
déroule à moscou un yvelinois oeuvre en
coulisses dans les coulisses de
l'événement c'est karl olive le maire de
poissy ancien directeur des sports à
canal+ est officier de liaison pour la
fifa en charge de la gestion à des
droits des médias il a répondu à nos
questions depuis la russie entretien
enregistré à la mi jeu
[Musique]
bonjour karl olive
oui mais vous êtes depuis la rue si vous
êtes maire de poissy vice président du
conseil départemental des yvelines et
vous assurez donc en russie pour la fifa
la mission d'officiers de liaison
pendant cette coupe du monde en russie
vous gérez les droits des médias pendant
la compétition
première question pourquoi vous avez été
choisi pour cette mission je rappelle
toujours que le que la fonction de maire
n'est pas un métier en tant que tels que
comme un certain nombre de collègues
nous avons des métis prouve que le bien
est un métier de journaliste et
producteur oui et que aujourd'hui
j'assume une charge de charge de
fonctions de chargé de mission auprès de
la fifa ici en russie pour gérer ce
qu'on appelle les détenteurs de droits
je suis à la fois sur moscou avec une
formation qui a duré quatre jours
je suis arrivé à saransk au sud de
moscou il ya maintenant trois jours
d'accord pour préparer le match entre le
pérou et le danemark qui aura lieu
samedi
alors vous le disiez vous êtes toujours
dans cette fonction de journaliste parce
que vous avez été journaliste notamment
directeur des sports à canal+ c'est une
sorte de retour aux sources pour renouer
en quelque sorte avec vos anciens amours
il vous ils vous ont jamais peut-être
quitter aussi ses anciens amours pour
rien vous cacher je sais pas vraiment
lâcher complètement puisque j'assure
même cela la sanction de merck est
vraiment passionnante et qui me plaît
énormément prend énormément de temps et
une passion en tant que tel évidemment
comme la très grande majorité de mes
collègues ce soit à la ville de poissy
où tu es partement des yvelinois la
communauté grand paris seine et oise
il n'en demande pas moins qui me semble
très important de toujours conserver un
pied dans la société civile
alors non ce n'est pas un retour aux
sources puisque j'étais en 2010 en
afrique du sud j'étais en 2011 pour les
jeux mondiaux militaires à rio donc
c'est des choses qui me passionne
j'essaie de ma part j'essaie d'apporter
ma pierre a modestement à à l'édifice en
étant
la charge est de pouvoir gérer un
certain nombre de médias
il ya pas moins de 23 min journalistes
qui sont accrédités pendant la coupe du
monde
justement ça consiste en quoi cette
mission gérer les droits des médias
pendant une telle compétition ça ça
consiste en quoi
en fait typiquement vous voyez ce matin
nous avons reçu des partenaires de
médias des routes argentines de france
du japon
toutes ces personnes là ont des
fonctions bien précises qu'il faut
installer dans les stades
que ce soit en position aux
commentateurs que ce soit autour du
terrain derrière des caméras que ce soit
avant le match parce qu'on a des
présentations ou des annonces position
où que ce soit à la mi temps des matchs
pour interviewer le joueur qui va
rentrer aux vestiaires véritablement une
bataille navale et sur l'ensemble des
vestales de la coupe du monde
nous sommes deux mille sept cents à
effectuer pas seulement cette charge
mais a participé à à la sous traitance
de l'événement on vous le disait oui
alors pour rien vous cacher on est nous
il part le match de samedi
et c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas du tout
une ambiance formidable
une organisation exceptionnelle et je
peux vous dire que la joie des russes et
fait plaisir à voir
on a vraiment le sentiment le d'or
participer qui veulent savourer leurs
vins du monde ici en russie
une dernière question alors
ah je crois d'abord que le travail
effectué par didier deschamps et travail
efficace est exceptionnel avec la
rigueur qu'on lui connaît je pense que
quand vous avez remporté en tant que
capitaine la ligue des champions le
titre de champion du monde un titre de
champion de france que vous participez
comme comme finaliste d'un euro parce
que quand on a un sélectionneur à
l'image de l'idée deschamps je pense
qu'on peut faire confiance à à l'équipe
de france et le travail fait par le
président le graet et essais de l'équipe
que je crois pouvoir dire qu'on est
dangereux alors je dis pas et ce serait
présomptueux d'affirmer que l'équipe de
france évidemment du monde ce serait un
formidable clin d'oeil vingt ans après
simplement ce que vous pensez que on a
toutes les cartes en main pour pouvoir
effectuer un bon premier tour le match
de samedi va être un match important
contre l'australie et je pense que le
match contre le pérou auquel j'aurais la
chance de participer puisque après ça
rend ce que je serai sera un match qui
sera très important il aura lieu le 21
juin prochain est la france qui rentre
dans cette coupe du monde est
vous assurez pendant cette publicité de
rêver 78 merci je rappelle vous assurer
pendant cette coupe du monde la mission
d'officiers de liaison pour la fifa et
vous êtes aussi le maire de poissy et
vice président du conseil départemental
des yvelines
[Musique]
et à l'occasion de la coupe du monde de
football nous consacrions notre dossier
de la semaine au mondial vu dans les
yvelines suite et fin dans le passé ce
soir direction est les années 80 a joué
en josas avant clairefontaine l'équipe
de france a pendant longtemps utilisé
les terrains de la commune pour se
préparer aux grandes compétitions
internationales
certains habitants se rappelle avec
nicolas kirillovitch et nicolas landry
jouy en josas à l'ouest de paris le lieu
traditionnel de rassemblement de
l'équipe de france avant ses rendez vous
importants des rendez vous importants
comme l'euro 84 les hommes du
sélectionneur michel hidalgo ont
construit leur victoire européenne sur
deux terrains à jouy en josas au sein du
campus de l'école de commerce hec et sur
le stade municipal jean-claude hamon et
ifs pignon deux anciens joueurs du club
local ont des souvenirs des
infrastructures j'espère un wc et un
tout petit local arbitres si les lions
ont changé aujourd'hui les souvenirs
restent intactes ex dirigeants de l'ue s
jouy en josas gens selon mme annie a
conservé des photos des joueurs de
l'époque
alors ça c'est des photos de l'équipe de
france bonnet rouge tour et coup didier
six tignasse michel platini encore 6
le tour des stars de l'époque janvion
tigana lors d'une interview que j'avais
crête à l'hôtel val de bièvre j'avais ne
faisait un journal à l'époque pour le
club de foot local et j'avais demandé à
faire une interview novembre 1981 les
français jouent leur qualification à la
coupe du monde contre les pays-bas au
parc des princes boulanger à l'époque
jean claude hamon se souvient avoir reçu
une commande de la directrice de l'hôtel
où résidaient les bleus allaient faire
un gâteau un petit peu rapidement parce
qu'elle est venue me voir le dimanche
pour lundi soir était fermée le lundi
mais bon travail pour elle et puis ils
ont gagné elle enfin le bateau était
dans l'équipe
les mecs en train de rigoler le gâteau
dans le parisien peut parier à l'époque
entre eux la fed va commencer à minuit
elle se terminera très tôt ce matin
ce n'est pas il est vrai toutes les
nuits concept la qualification
vous pouvez avoir jusqu'à 2000 personnes
peut-être 100 du monde il y avait du
monde et puis puisqu'il est très bon
enfant quoi surtout c'était les gens ils
rentraient à partir de 1988 l'équipe de
france s'installe à clairefontaine la
commune devient alors le centre
technique national du football français
à jouy en josas le football continue de
faire vibrer les amateurs du ballon rond
et ne manquez pas juste après ce journal
un 7,8 débat spécial football à
l'occasion de l'ouverture du mondial une
question plus locale à laquelle
tenteront de répondre nicolas qui rit le
vide c'est ses invités
le département des yvelines est il une
terre de football c'est à suivre tout à
l'heure sur tv 78 ce jeudi 14 juin c'est
la journée mondiale des donneurs de sang
alors que les réserves nationales sont
en baisse les dons augmentent à saint
quentin en yvelines
le théâtre national accueille désormais
les donneurs un reportage de tout in
ireland haut et patrick jacques de
dixmude des donneurs de sang au théâtre
face aux flux de donneurs la collecte
prend ses quartiers au théâtre national
de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya beaucoup plus d'espacé que je
pense aussi que ça change beaucoup de
choses pour les pour les personnes qui
travaillent ici qui sont dans des
conditions quand même à mon sens plus
puis confortable tu manques on est
entouré par un staff compétent quelqu'un
donc on peut faire ça en confiance sans
aucun problème huit personnes de
l'établissement français du sang a
accueilli des dons contribution à
l'entr'aide civisme c'est ce qui motive
les donneurs je sais qu'il ya un besoin
et que voilà c'est pas c'est un petit
peu de temps s'est il pas enfin voila
c'est un peu de temps et ça peut servir
à beaucoup d'autres personnes donc c'est
pour ça que j'essaie de venir assez
régulièrement pour nous c'est une
période
un peu critique ou en tout cas on est
très attentifs pendant les vacances les
franciliens partent la plupart or or
hors de paris hors de l'ile-de-france et
ceux qui sont restés ils ont d'autres
choses à penser que de donner du sang
par contre est malade
ils sont toujours présents les collectes
de sang vont se poursuivre d'ici à la
fin de l'année le théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
cinq autres collectes
si vous êtes un utilisateur régulier des
transports la période est forcément
difficile avec la grève en pointillés
des cheminot à la sncf est les
détenteurs de pass navigo et de la carte
imagine r pourront adresser leur demande
de remboursement à partir du 19 jan un
site pour le faire non dédommagement
point transilien.com lé remboursement
concerne les mois d'avril et de mai est
à noter que la réforme ferroviaire
motifs de départ de la grève des
cheminots a été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale ce jeudi
depuis la semaine dernière une
soixantaine de caravanes des gens du
voyage s'est installé à au quartier de
la bretonnière à voisins le bretonneux
la communauté occupe illégalement le
terrain de la coulée verte ils
s'engagent à partir le 23 juin les
précisions de camille lambert et de
nicolas kirillovitch la coulée verte un
lieu de promenade à voisins le
bretonneux transformé en camping de
fortune depuis le 7 juin une communauté
catholique de gens du voyage s'est
installée illégalement sur ce terrain
appartenant à saint quentin en yvelines
la ville n'a pas eu d'autre choix que de
les laisser la police nationale a eu
l'ordre en direct du préfet de laisser
faire puisque des ternes qui ont été
rapportés à m'ont élu c'est un moindre
mal puisque je crois qu'avec le golfe
ils essaient de protéger un petit peu
les alentours le terrain thales on n'a
pas le choix c'est la loi la loi ne nous
aide pas parce qu'une forte les carats
valant des télés on ne peut plus les
envoyer la mairie a donc mis à
disposition des conteneurs et des
branchements en eau et électricité pour
la soixantaine de caravanes
mais dans ce quartier résidentiel de la
bretonnière avec une école les
inquiétudes sont nombreuses
les habitants sont excessivement
remontée et il ya de quoi
je crois que nous sommes dans une
situation un peu inhabituel le cadre de
vie levy sinois ils sont profondément
attachés et là on voit des gens un
groupement massif s'installer il ya des
dégradations de terrain je souhaitais
que l'été que les terras le terrain soit
nettoyé bien évidemment contacté par nos
soins la communauté n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer
le responsable s'est engagé auprès de la
mairie à partir le 23 juin et à nettoyer
les lieux avant leur départ 20 ans
qu'elle apporte une aide aux familles de
la ville dans le besoin la boutique
alimentaire de montigny le bretonneux a
fêté hier mercredi son anniversaire une
célébration avec les élus et le centre
communal d'action social installé place
george sand la boutique alimentaire
propose des produits gratuits de
première nécessité et d'autres payants
mais à des prix bas grâce à un
partenariat avec les commerçants locaux
cent cinquante familles iny monteyne ont
pu bénéficier de ce service en 2017
il a été créé à l'initiative de l'ancien
maire nicolas abou écouter ses propos au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude la
boutique alimentaire a été créée
effectivement à l'initiative de nicolas
a beau parce que je me souviens d'avoir
une discussion avec lui me disant les
restos du coeur c'est vraiment
extraordinaire mais en fait les gens
mangent de novembre à mars
et entre les deux il n'y a plus rien et
donc du coup il a été décidé qu'on
allait essayer de faire cette boutique
alimentaire pour répondre aux besoins
des familles nîmes antenne bien entendu
tous les jours la boutique alimentaire
est ouverte le matin du lundi au
vendredi
nocturne le mercredi pour les familles
qui travaillent et l'accès est proposée
après étude du dossier par la ccrs autre
anniversaire celui de l' agence
technique départementale ingénierie la
structure fêtait ses quatre ans hier au
domaine de madame elisabeth à versailles
le président du sénat gérard larcher a
été présent ingénierie apporte aux
communes rurales des yvelines une
assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé dans les
domaines du bâtiment de la voirie et de
l'urbanisme
une nouvelle mission vient s'ajouter
pour ces quatre ans la préservation et
l'entretien du patrimoine local propos
recueillis par nicolas kirillovitch ça
c'est important parce que nous ne
l'avions pas avant maintenant nous
allons la voir avec cinq personnes en
plus qui vont être donc transféré du
département d'ingénierie pour voir
s'occuper de tous les problèmes du
patrimoine c'est ça peut être par
semaine culturelle c'est important des
statuts par exemple des bornes des
chapelles des églises là beaucoup
beaucoup de le patrimoine historique
dans les yvelines et ça
désormais on a on a cette compétence est
bien sûr également on va déménager à
rambouillet et ça ça marque
le développement la croissance des
génériques
une convention est d'ailleurs signée ce
soir pour officialiser cette nouvelle
compétence entre ingénierie le conseil
départemental des yvelines et la
fondation de sauvegarde de l'art
français
c'est le premier pôle commercial du
département saint quentin en yvelines a
lancé hier mercredi une série de
rencontres à destination des commerçants
objectif faire le point sur la stratégie
commerciale de l'agglomération mais
aussi avoir un retour sur les
problématiques rencontrées première zone
un rang de première zone concernée à
maurepas coignières ont fait le point
avec aurélie rose une première
concertation qui commence tout d'abord
par un état des lieux avec plus de 500
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
annuel la zone maurepas coignières est
le deuxième pôle majeur de
l'agglomération sur les 160 mille mètres
carrés de zone commerciale on dénombre
250 magasins qui génère plus de 2000
emplois un territoire qui présente donc
de nombreuses forces
même si les commerçants présents pointé
du doigt quelques faiblesses je
m'aperçois que cette zone a des petits
problèmes de fréquentation on a une zone
qui est un petit peu des articles en
semaine et j'étais très inquiet de la
non réactivité je suis venu ici pour
m'informer et j'en ressors un peu plus
satisfait car je m'aperçois que d'autres
gens que moir ont les mêmes soucis
les interrogations et travaille au
développement de cette zone hyper
important quand on doit s'adresser à
quelqu'un on a souvent interlocuteur
ça passe d'un nom à laudun non à l'autre
et on arrive souvent pas à voir la
personne dont on a besoin et donc là ça
permet ce que tout le monde se connaît
on sait à peu près qui va s'occuper de
quoi mieux connaître les attentes des
commerçants des propriétaires et des
gestionnaires de sites afin de
développer au mieux cette zone
voici l'objectif de saint quentin en
yvelines pour repenser la stratégie
commerciale du territoire il y aura
d'autres évidemment réunion mais on
reste toujours maintenant en contact
parce que l'objectif c'est aussi d'avoir
leurs coordonnées d'avoir aussi
d'évolution de chiffre d'affaires pour
voir un peu comment il se situe
prochaines zones concernées par ces
concertations plaisir et les
clayes-sous-bois en octobre prochain
on en parlait avec ce début du ravec en
début de journal une compétition s'ouvre
avec la coupe du monde de football une
autre aura lieu en septembre golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la ryder cup bien sûr qui se
déroulera du 28 au 30 septembre alors à
l'occasion de ce duel amérique europe au
golf trois repas de gala seront
organisées au profit de l'association
handigolf pour en parler autour de la
table avec moi trois invités eric denis
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le délégué
régional de l'association handigolf en
ile de france christelle videmment
renforce
vous êtes la présidente de dar partage
points comme c'est l'une des entreprises
qui à l'origine de cette initiative et
nous avons également robert cadalbert
bonsoir bonsoir cofondateur darpa par
partage pardon ancien président de saint
quentin en yvelines pour le pôle site et
vous êtes à l'origine de cette
initiative alors je précise que ces
trois repas de gala auront lieu les 13
20 et 27 septembre ça se déroule au
restaurant les templiers à elancourt une
compétition oenologique sera d'ailleurs
organisé ça sera l'une des animations
proposées c'est la one year cup qui se
déroulera à cette occasion on va en
parler juste après déjà robert cadalbert
pourquoi organiser cette initiative
cette initiative vient de l'initiative
qu'a fait le président de la fédération
française de golf
monsieur barbaret quand il m'a dit est
ce que tu veux nous aider à organiser la
ryder cup et je suis dit ok mais c'est
le golfe pour tous et par le golfe pour
simplement une élite c'était ça la base
de notre candidature et la raideur 4 et
dans cette demande d'avoir le
golf pour tous bien évidemment il ya le
travail de fait par l'agglomération sur
les scolaires qui a été très important
avec la vie associative mais on a choisi
nous d'aider fortement le handigolf à se
développer à 50 ans de vignes et en
france en général
justement profiter de tels événements la
ryder cup c'est idéal pour pour parler
de l'andi sport du handigolf là en
l'occurrence à fait à la fois c'est pour
faire tenir nos engagements un
engagement par rapport à la candidature
c'était le golfe pour tous c'est pas le
golfe pour une élite et en plus c'est
vrai que on a une demande particulière
c'est que le golf sa fille un petit
événement aussi après la ryder cup
s'appelle les jeux olympiques
et on a aussi fortement vie que le golf
le handigolf soit épreuve du para
olympiques alors éric tenez vous
représenter l'association handigolf elle
est dédié justement aux golfeurs
handicapées qu'elles sont quelles sont
ses missions à cette association
notre mission c'est de faire participer
un maximum de personnes handicapées au
boeuf bien le golfe si on part pour une
insertion sociale
nos actions sont surtout sur des
animations
un petit peu partout en france et en
outre-mer aussi nous sommes et nous
organisons aussi des grands prix des
championnats handigolf alors derrière
l'initiative on l'a dit art partage
points comme il n'y a pas que cette
entreprise qui est sûre cette initiative
christelle évidemment peut-être déjà un
mot sur art partage we are partage c'est
une s'est porté par la société impulsion
et on en fait on fait la promotion des
artistes à travers les entreprises avec
les entreprises et on crée aussi des
événements et la voix une heure coop on
est en état est un événement que l'on
porte avec nos partenaires le coin du
sommelier qui est autour du vin c'est
une compétition et oenologiques
on est porté aussi avec l'arche des arts
on porte ce projet avec l'arche désert
et puis le restaurant des templiers au
sein duquel on fait cette c3 soirée de
gala d'être soutenus et éric denis par
voilà ces entreprises il y aura aussi à
ses repas de gala des personnalités je
pense à roger zabel journaliste jean
louis charon qui est le président de la
fédération française de golf c'est
forcément positif pour votre association
c'est ce qui nous permet d'avoir une
vitrine sur sûr nous quoi donc c'est
très important
roger zabel et parrain de notre
association depuis un petit moment et on
oeuvre beaucoup avec lui sur des
programmes de partenariat entreprise
avant qu'on parle de winter cup
de quoi a besoin aujourd'hui votre
association notre association est là on
n'a pas de subventions d'état ou local
puisqu'on est sur toute la france
donc on ne marche que par donation et
que par donation quasiment donc voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce genre
d'animation on l'a dit pour ces trois
repas de gala il y aura une animation
phare c'est la warner cup une
compétition a eu logiquement mettra aux
prises les territoires viticoles
américains et européens vous est
d'ailleurs venu avec le trophée de cette
winer cup c'est un trophée allégorie qui
a été réalisée par l'artiste gérard
galop alors concrètement m m en face
territoire américain et européen là on
est vraiment dans l'esprit de la riderz
c'était un clin d'oeil on pense qu'au
niveau de nos chances on a plus de
chances sont tous les français en tous
les cas là dans la compétition
je pense que le terroir français sera
bien représentée peut-être nous bien
mieux que celui de terroir anglais
comment ça va se dérouler justement cet
honneur c'est simplement de façon
ludique
pendant les repas de gala parce que la
finalité c'est d'abord des repas de gala
pour effritement obtenir des fonds pour
handigolf à cette même salle la base et
cette compétition avec un bon clin
d'oeil avec on aura des dégustations en
aveugle d'un lavage à chaque chaque plat
il ya 20 à 1,20 b1 qui représentera
l'amérique et l'autre qui reprendrait en
europe et tous les convives pourront
voter pour savoir quel est le meilleur
voilà et à la fin des trois repas comme
pour la ryder cup qui se fait aussi en
trois jours on fera le décompte de kira
gagner est ce que c'est l'amérique ou
l'europe et je précise que cette
compétition sera conduite par ugo rookie
et oenologue internationale alors ce
trophée à gagner y aura aussi de
nombreux le de nombreux lots pardon je
vais y arriver à gagner en particulier
bien sûr on fait en parrainage avec le
golf national et y aura des greens fille
sur l'albatros alors pas à fin septembre
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le droit d'aller
jouer soin de battre hausse vers 76
réservé quand même aux équipes d'europe
et des états unis
mais après la compétition
on offrira un certain nombre de green
filles sur l'albatros aux participants
petit tour de table il nous reste moins
d'une minute qu'est ce qui ferait que
ces trois repas de gala soit réussie des
soirées réussies
quels sont les ingrédients qui doivent
être réunies du monde
bien sûr on attend surtout on s'adresse
surtout aux entreprises
on a fait quand d'étape cirque les
entreprises peuvent inviter leurs
clients leurs partenaires pour ce repas
de gala au profit de randy golf et puis
après pas forcément que l'europe et le
patrimoine européen gagne face au
patrimoine américain
eh bien merci à vous trois robert
cadalbert éric denis et et christelle
videmment d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que ces trois repas de gala
auront lieu lé 13 20 et 27 septembre au
restaurant les templiers à elancourt une
compétition se déroulera à l'occasion de
ces trois repas assez launer cup
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi le replay de cette
édition est à consulter sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]